okay speaking about cloaking is there
any evidence that suggests well ufos are
associated with orbs at least
anecdotally firstly what's the reason
for that and then second
is there any evidence that you know that
suggests that these orbs may be
more plentiful than we think perhaps
around us whether in homes or outside
cityscapes just cloaked yeah the problem
with orb the word orb is is you're not
going to get a common definition from
most people everybody thinks a word
means something else some people think
an orb is a little plasma ball others
say it's
much much bigger and intelligently
controlled
um you know orb is kind of a general
catch-all when you say is an orb related
to ufo well by definition it is a ufo
it's unidentified and it's flying or
it's a you know it's in our atmosphere
and uh
it's an object it's something we don't
know what it is so by definition an orb
is a uap but the question is is it a uap
in the sense that we we're talking about
uaps whether lenticular type shape or
maybe a cylindrical shape or a
triangular vehicle
i think the jury's still out there does
seem to be some information that
suggests that orbs as you call them are
sometimes
associated with other uap sightings that
there are uaps in the sky and then you
see these little balls of light
you know um
the problem is it's it's a very
generalized term
we now know for a fact
that things such as ball lightning are
real is that an orb well yeah at times
it looks like an orb to me um
other times when you have large
large amounts of energy being released
into into the atmosphere and the
environment let's talk about tectonic
movement for example where these titanic
forces uh right underneath the surface
of the earth um creating this this this
this
plasma effect in the atmosphere where
you get these different colors uh
shooting into the sky and and again orbs
if you will
um being reported and seen and even
captured on camera uh but that that's
that's an orb that that i think we can
all agree is probably um being
manufactured um naturally now are there
orbs that are intelligently controlled
well we did talk about that at atip you
know one of the questions where when you
look at the
the the different shapes and sizes of
vehicles orbs tend to be almost like i
guess in in a vernacular sense think of
a uav
think of a drone um the pro the the they
tend to be described as being much
smaller highly maneuverable uh different
colors sometimes red sometimes green
sometimes yellow sometimes blue
um is it possible that those colors are
are
are indicative of mission set right is
it are the blue ones doing certain
things where the reds are doing
something else and their purpose is
something else where the yellows and
whites are doing something else
it's certainly plausible
um
you know i i i don't dismiss that at all
the problem is we just don't have enough
information because it appears that the
the
these orbs tend to be small that it's
really hard to argue the case that they
are being occupied by any type of
biological organism now it doesn't mean
that they're not it just means that you
know it
we haven't seen that yet
um
you know we don't know what these are
these perhaps some sort of unmanned
reconnaissance uh capability that are
kicked out um
not much different than we use drones
ourselves right to do certain types of
reconnaissance missions um we don't know
it's certainly possible
the reasoning behind my question is that
tom delong i recall was saying one
shouldn't do ce5 i'm going to get you to
explain what ce5 is but anyway one
shouldn't do ce5 and when one does it
often orbs are associated with it and
one thinks oh that's great because i'm
inducing some contact and tom said
be careful one shouldn't do that lightly
so
that to me implies
that there's something nefarious or
potentially nefarious about these orbs
well i mean look i'd say the same thing
you know don't mess around with
electricity unless you're a licensed
electrician be careful because you can
get zapped that's true with anything
that's not just orbs that's electricity
that's swimming pools that's everything
um you know just i i can't speak for tom
you know i don't know what tom meant by
that
but i can tell you that that
general word of caution i think is is is
appropriate for for just about anything
out there you know if you don't know
what you're getting into just
just be mindful um
you know
there are potentially things that go
bump in the night and and and it's not
all you know um necessarily uh good or
bad you know it's not all sunflowers
like your cup well you know anytime you
go go snorkeling look i'm an avid scuba
diver i've been scuba diving my whole
life um you know there's always a remote
risk when you go scuba diving in some of
these beautiful coral reefs you know
what there's a risk you're going to come
up against a shark now not all sharks
are going to do anything but if you're
carrying a you know a bag of of fresh
fish that you wound up sparing uh and
and are now bleeding out of this bag and
dead
chances are you may attract a lot more
attention than just a curious shark you
may be attracting a hungry shark and now
you got to kind of pay attention so
um
you know i i
i think that's wise advice on just about
everything that we we
we do you know i live here in wyoming
where a lot of people like to go go
splunking and and you know adventuring
into caves
but again you know you have to have the
right equipment be careful when you go
into a cave you know make sure you've
got light make sure you've got you know
gear that can get you in and out and
rope and whatnot